welcome back, our studio sand forests and
we have such an unexpected guest for you,
you know the world, this is not a completely
unexpected guest, because in
fact I’m sure that in the chat they have already
asked where did Peter go if you have
regular viewers who know how to
chairs  they creak above our heads and
now these viewers periodically ask the
question where did Peter go here stamina connections
one in only peter svidler who just got
through to us and now he will tell us everything the
impression of the opinion and so on if of
course we can hear it you each
other on you still  everything else is
trying
new impressions, absolutely
stunning, I’m kind of after
your yesterday’s guest, I don’t know
what to say, but it continues to be more
perfect shayan sq some and
today as a whole doesn’t change
anything, that is, in a sense,
I start to root for 1  ha, because how would
our two of us how to say favorites at the
end at the end of the rapid part, they are
either because of fatigue or because of
some  general nervousness, but they both
demonstrate such a kind of nervous,
uneven and completely different
game that it would actually be very
attractive for such a story
if, on these last two hundred meters, they
were bypassed by some kind of 3 horse, but ford,
but such that  I suspect that I won’t have time all the
same Chinese Chinese matador, but I
have a lot of metaphors in one
sentence, of course it’s interesting to watch,
but at the same time my eyes climb on my forehead from
what is happening, well, that is, there is a feeling
that the competition in the ability to yawn pieces
in one move is
sometimes difficult but checkmate  in 2 moves, the chutney
put here on you, as if
people are already not content with simple things,
like a rook winter in one move, it
’s already, as it were, the standards passed,
it’s already considered that
if no one returns the mate in that [ __ ] and they
and the other side of this  fashion will not
set up that this tour was in vain I and
how would I be inside you are understandable I am
absolutely not my genre at all
how to say lightly laugh at
chess  players of this level, but I
kind of say all this with the caveat that it’s
quite obvious that they play
much weaker from deception three heads are
weaker than their usual level and the ability
here, apart from general fatigue, the mind has
no guess why this happens, but
let’s say in the case of a lemon  in general,
he rested for some time and why it is so hard for him,
let's say, these last two
days, and everything goes so well for him, as
if one game,
we recognize the great Armenian chess player, and the
game following it is somehow
completely indistinct
and strange in general  extremely of course of
course difficult to understand
tournaments we have not yet started talking about and 455
but by the way to the conversation
about e4 e5 queen h5 because yes, and
we even exchanged a little bit in the chat
yes this morning all the same the
opinion of the general public about
because  I especially press the press there, many of the
press understand how it doesn’t sell, I spoke
about this, I also can’t say
that I carefully studied how to
How many circles on the water have spread because of
this, but I have seen some views on the
topic that poor poor teachers of
children's chess who would now find it much
more difficult to explain to children why one should not
try to checkmate queen b7, as if
when the world champion does it in a
tournament game  but besides that, well,
it seems to me quite obvious the
same as you said yesterday on the air that
when mars starts doing such things in the
opening, it can be called tilt, but
you can call it because what
you were talking about, as far as I understand yesterday,
it’s completely  an obvious such easy to
read sign that he is completely
furious with his game he is a man
who is centuries old it is characteristic of me
that it is characteristic of him even exaggerating
the manner he hates to play chess
for him the feeling that he plays chess
badly the old man he knows how well and he
certainly knows how well  we know the
pressure is an issue for him, this feeling is
completely unbearable and at that
moment he begins to look for how  oh, the way out of
this, it’s like some kind of valve is
needed to let off this steam, and we also
observed this at the world blitz championship,
where there was also a completely
enchanting debut when he lost the
porn start and then e4 e5 pier
h5 returned  who haven’t returned for a long time, I do
n’t think that the magician of us is from precisely in
this respect, he’s such a fairly pure
person I know that he doesn’t have masks, so
he immediately enters a state of
such dissatisfaction with his own game, he is
very critical of this,
others are somehow restrained by  it all
reads it reads much much
more obvious, it seems to me that you really
can’t confuse the test with anything, he doesn’t really try to
mask it in any special way, that is, but what about the
classics,
what do you think, that is, it can change, it
can return to each of the magnus
that we saw before  the end of
July this year, the mouse is very very dependent on
how it starts, but it’s clear that in the
classics already all this ballast would
stop the knife already  for sure, we won’t see any of these,
as it were, opening debuts,
we’ll see these any more,
everything will be put on a much
more solid footing and, accordingly, this
will again remove a huge huge part of
this very statistical spread,
but as for the dominance that
we saw in all tournaments, the argument
well, if he wins the first first pair,
but not let's say 1 2 if somewhere
at the start he manages to win a good game
, as a whole, as it were, the nervous
system, as far as we know, is quite
stable and not a large influx of
positive emotions, and everything in general can
to return to where there and its own circles, although I
think that it’s right to those
completely magical things that were shown to
us in the spring,
but it’s hard to imagine that for
three days after all this, you don’t
know what word to call a person
will suddenly develop again in the
manner in which he  tore well, anything
can happen, but I think that if it starts well,
then it may be inherent, because I’m here  tell me,
perhaps, Levon Aronian very often even mentioned his participation in
the Grand Prix draw
in such a factor as age,
tell me how hard it is for you to play with
elite chess players, well, it’s not easy, but the
teeth of the side, it was always like,
again, I can be myself  I'm cheating but to me
so the results in a way
confirm this let's say for me always
if I choose between a genre I don't want to
say try to score plus 5 strong
swiss ones don't I want
to play 2 persuading tournaments of 22 categories instead
I always chose for myself 2 world
tournament 20 categories country group
provided that it is not so
easy to get into it and I’m on the track
some play it is necessary but it’s already better than
me obviously completely I’m much
easier going to me much clearer goals and
objectives
but of course it’s all from year to year
it gets harder and the last
time I played like a really
tight supertournament it was the
Dortmund tournament where I found  you clarino out of
three and then fell down and finished
the fifty-kopeck tournament with a huge bust and could
finish -2, that is, the optimal form is not easy, of
course
.  optimal form,
I still think that I can
compete with this field, but where to
get it and who knows where to get it we
here you know how they say that
the next round begins hurry hurry
look for the form
we are such a small spoiler that you
seem to be yes  the form is fine spoiler that
you also seem to be returning to
st louis right I downloaded september
to
st louis yes how I hope
to play well at least in this event with
great pleasure I always play in
this genre so let's see how it
goes oh well  thank you for not forgetting the
studio b as it was said in the
classics studio my home is dear
thanks lighter but then the fight with
chairs yes and this is good luck to you on your
difficult path
thanks 5 yes and we are actually
starting already actually starting the
next tour poison